Tucker Carlson of course Tucker is one
of the few people that is doing anything
roughly approximate to honesty in in
corporate media here he is summarizing
the conditions of East Palestine
East Palestine is overwhelmingly white
and it's politically conservative more
than 70 percent of the voters in the
surrounding County supported Donald
Trump in the last election that
shouldn't be relevant but as you're
about to hear it very much is
11 days ago 150 car Train derailed in
East Palestine and when it did it spewed
poisonous chemicals onto the ground and
into the surface waters after the crash
the Ohio State EPA found evidence of
butyl acrylate in the Ohio River as well
as in the creeks and streams that feed
it
now this was a concern for more than
simply East Palestine given that the
Ohio River supplies drinking water to
about a tenth of the entire U.S
population
so this train derailment was an
environmental disaster not an
environmental disaster like climate
changes but an actual environmental
disaster okay so this is serious stuff
10 of drinking water to Americans right
you can look at all the videos of the
Dead Fish and the dead frogs and the
dead birds and other animals and the
chickens dying on top of the fact that
we already have this national issue with
chickens not laying eggs we haven't
covered that yet but that's another one
right now that's really bizarre and then
the EPA shows up now you would think we
have this whole movement
in America and and seemingly a global
movement that endlessly cares about the
environment right you should not turn
lights on you should not drive this car
you shouldn't cook your eggs on that
stove and they're always screaming about
it but for some reason with this thing
these toxic chemicals in our water this
unbelievable I mean these fires in the
plume of smoke we're going to show you
another image on that that looks like an
atom bomb was dropped there there
they're being awfully quiet on this uh
here's a little bit more from Tucker but
we basically nuke the town with
chemicals
so then representatives from the EPA the
Environmental Protection Agency arrived
to restore calm yes an EPA spokesman
explained chemicals from the derail
train did enter the local Watershed and
yes they did Kill fish but the drinking
water supply remains totally safe the
fish are dead but go ahead and fill your
thermos and Brew some coffee
everything's fine
now we don't know if the locals in East
Palestine are drinking the water tonight
but we can tell you the buy
demonstration doesn't seem too concerned
about it either way Donald Trump got
over 71 percent of the vote in the
county in the last presidential election
that's not exactly the Democratic
party's core demographic
fentanyl toxic waste spill whatever
they're not our voters okay in one
instance here I don't want to be quite
as cynical as Tucker as being on the
election side of this thing so I don't
know that the administration is ignoring
this because these are you know like
white Trump voters there I don't know
that much I wouldn't put it past this
administration because I think they're
pretty bad people but I don't know that
much the point really is that there is a
reason they are ignoring this ecological
disaster I don't know that we know that
reason yet but for the EPA to show up
there the Environmental Protection
Agency which is an extremely well-funded
agency that has gone well beyond the
bounds of what it was originally founded
to do that it is telling people drink
the water drink the water with all the
freaking dead fish and the dead frogs go
ahead and drink that water
thank you
[Music]